A great Halloween party is nothing to get spooked about.
Check out these simple ways to trick out your treats...
...and make this year's party memorable.
Halloween calls for cupcakes, right?
Just place some zombie hands on the icing to take them from fun to frightening.
And how about these cookies?
Use cake mix to make them monstrously good.
And add some eerie eyeballs to make them a big hit with boys and ghouls.
Here's how to make your Halloween party punch creepy cool.
Just grab a latex glove.
Make sure it's not the powdered kind and fill it with water.
Freeze it.
Cut away the glove and float it in a bowl of fruit punch.
And that's how to scare up a Halloween party without spending too much time or money.
Your guests are in for a real treat.